[Music]
we love the loud house for what we love
even more are all the pop-culture
references this show makes from classic
TV shows and movies to Charlie Brown and
SpongeBob SquarePants we're sure you
missed at least a couple of references
give this video a thumbs up and hit that
subscribe button to never miss another
video again now let's check out pop
culture connections in the loud house
that will make your jaw drop TV shows
and movies let's start with some of the
most noticeable references ever
especially if you pay attention to the
show's intro you can find these little
shout outs at the beginning of every
loud house episode and honestly they're
pretty creative of course we're talking
about the episode titles which almost
always reference classic movies and
involve plenty of other pop-culture
references to boys in a baby episode is
a reference to the popular old-school
comedy movie titled three men and a baby
toads and Tiaras is a shout out to the
controversial toddlers in tiaras and the
loudest yard refers to Adam Sandler's
movie called The Longest Yard season
two's cheater by the Dozen is a subtle
shout-out to the Cheaper by the Dozen
and pulp friction is obviously referring
to the pulp fiction it's not clear
whether these are movies and shows Chris
Savino loved the most
we're pretty sure you can easily spot a
pop-culture reference in every single
loud house title so make sure to tell us
which ones you discovered if you could
make your own loud house reference for
movie titles what would it be we'll
favorite the most creative comment the
loud house crew did you know you can
spot the entire loud house production
crew in at least one episode this is the
one that's only known by true loud house
fans who know what the production crew
look like but if you've watched a lot of
behind-the-scenes clips you probably
know the names and looks of the people
that make this show
they include Chris Savino the creator of
the show and plenty of other staff
members you can catch most of them in
for Bros about to rock their caricatures
of the actual crew members that work so
hard to create this awesome show and a
bearded guy with a purple sweater is
actually Chris Savino from what it looks
like the staff that works behind the
scenes on the loud house is actually
pretty cool and some of them have an
amazing fashion sense they're definitely
the people we'd love to hang out with
you can see them again in the loudest
yard they're the ones that are in the
crowd watching the game we're kind of
jealous because what could be better
than seeing yourself and your cartoon
version on the show you're actually
working for our next pop-culture
reference is one of the moves
popular video games that's been around
for a while and inspired quite a few
memes World of Warcraft this is a
reference you'd never understand unless
you're a gamer that watches way too many
YouTube videos and if you are we can
totally relate as can the loud house
it's one of the oddest references of all
times but didn't spell it out the loud
house pays a tribute to a viral World of
Warcraft gaming video in the video the
players are discussing what kind of
weapons and other equipment they need
for the battle when a player called
Leroy Jenkins decides to skip the
orientation and go headfirst into the
combat completely unprepared he releases
his battle cry the clip became a popular
meme and for some reason it made its way
onto the loud house the kids are playing
a game that looks very similar to World
of Warcraft rusty spokes shouts his name
in the exact same way as Leroy Jenkins
player did in the popular World of
Warcraft meme and charges into the
battle completely unprepared this could
very well be a coincidence but since
this show has so many other references
we really doubt it hit songs we all know
Lunars the rocker of the house and if
you've paid enough attention you
probably noticed she makes a lot of
references to some of the most popular
rock songs ever we always see a rockin
out but if you pay attention to what
she's actually saying toward siblings
you'll almost always be able to link our
line to some of the most popular songs
ever in no guts no glory she gives a
shout out to a CD C's most iconic song
for those about to rock we salute you in
project loud house she does Lincoln he
can't always get what he wants which is
a reference to the same name song by the
Rolling Stones in Lankershim she
channeled her inner Luanne and made a
pun out of Alice Cooper's school's out
by saying that it looks like pools out
for summer but it's not just rock songs
Luna makes all sorts of pop-culture
references in house music she actually
quoted Drake's lyrics from the motto and
in antisocial she even pays a tribute to
one of Britney Spears most popular songs
oops I did it again
we're pretty sure you can even find more
references to hit songs in louann's
words so if you ever rewatch the loud
house make sure to let us know of all
references you managed to find
Nickelodeon shows if there's anything
the loud house is good at it's paying a
tribute to other Nickelodeon shows it's
actually managed to surpass and it comes
to views and ratings but the show's real
talent is to squeeze as many references
as possible in a sink
and you won't believe how many
references you can find in link or swim
the loud family goes to a community
swimming pool where they try really hard
to have a good time even though the
lifeguards aren't appreciating their
adventures if you keep a close eye on
the seniors at the swimming pool
you'll catch some familiar faces from
other cartoons you can catch blue
pickles from Rugrats and Grandpa bill
from hey Arnold is on the bottom right
corner you can also see miss bitters
from invader zim and Miss Powell from
The Adventures of Jimmy Neutron
there's even Iroh from Avatar The Last
Airbender standing under the umbrella
tree watch the scene and see how many of
these characters you can spot might be
the only time you see all of these
cartoon seniors hang out together but
we're not done yet with cartoon
references make sure to stay tuned to
see which crowd favorite cartoon show is
the loud house totally obsessed with
Golden Girls younger kids might not
remember this one but if you're an older
fan you can test your TV show knowledge
with this reference we've talked about
Ella's for love episode in many of our
videos it's also one of the most
controversial episodes that managed to
get banned in several countries during
Lola's pageant in Ella's for love you
can see judges holding up different
scorecards in the audience pay close
attention to the two ladies holding the
number 8 & 9
can you recognize them their hair and
the glasses are pretty obvious tribute
to the Golden Girls one of the most
beloved American sitcoms the characters
names are Dorothy and Sophia and the
resemblance is uncanny it's hard to
believe the characters were just chosen
at random when they look so similar to
the golden girl if you're younger you
should definitely test your parents and
show them these two loud house
characters and see if they can recognize
them we bet there's at least a few that
will be able to tell their Dorothy and
Sophia Dennis the Menace unlike other
references this one is very hidden and
can easily be missed if you've never
heard of Dennis the Menace before it's
hidden in the name of one of the places
the characters from the show visit on a
few occasions and unless you're a super
fan of the show you probably totally
missed it the loud house characters
often visit a park that has a very
well-known name to anyone that loves old
school cartoons catch'em Park is shown
in several episodes including changing
the baby two boys and a baby income sale
way it's where toddlers come and play on
the playground and it's where you can
almost always find Lincoln doing
something with Lily but have you ever
noticed the connection with the name of
the park and Dennis the Menace it's in
the name catch'em refers to Hank Ketcham
who is responsible for the original
Dennis the Menace comic book it's safe
to say that the comic book was a huge
inspiration for Chris Savino the creator
of the show we found that this is the
only reference to Dennis the Menace on
the show so if you've seen any others
make sure to let us know now let's move
on to the final two references we never
even noticed these but they're present
in plenty of scenes throughout the show
peanuts we've already mentioned several
cartoon characters that appeared at the
community pool scene but peanuts and the
loud house have a connection that goes
beyond just a single scene Khalil Harris
the actor that voices Clyde also voices
Franklin in the 2014 peanuts series but
apart from that the show features
several shoutouts to the adorable
cartoon in homespun Lynn lout senior
tries to fix the TV antenna on the roof
when the kids finally get the picture
back you can see the opening scene from
a Charlie Brown Christmas on the TV and
read aloud the competition lists another
family with a very familiar name
it's the Van Pelt family from peanuts
serial offenders title card has a bowl
that has a pattern that's very similar
to Charlie Brown's shirt have you ever
paid attention to Lincoln's winter
outfit the brown hat the top the pants
and the shoes are all very similar to
Charlie Brown's winter outfit you can
find so many peanuts references it would
take at least 30 minutes to list all of
them we have a feeling these aren't just
a total coincidence and that Chris
Savino loves to hide these Easter eggs
in the loud house episodes spongebob and
last but not least it's the TV show that
the loud house actually surpassed on the
Nickelodeon ratings in 2016 spongebob
squarepants was no longer the number-one
cartoon show that spot belonged to the
loud house to make sure there are no
hard feelings over this victory the show
actually has quite a few references to
SpongeBob SquarePants
in the very first episode of this series
you can see the loud sisters fighting
over our remote but if you pay attention
to the TV you'll see a quick shot of
what seems to be a yellow sponge and a
starfish
it's definitely a shout-out to Sponge
Bob Squarepants in the fifth episode of
the second season you can also see
similar characters in Lisa's
kindergarten class these are just very
simple shapes that could be anything but
the color combination makes it very
clear which show they're referring to
pretty clever right and in the 12th
episode of the first season you can see
a star-shaped character on top of
Lincoln's trash that looks a lot like
Patrick Starr out of all references made
showing you today SpongeBob SquarePants
has to be our absolute favorite but
there are so many small references we
have missed if you're a super fan of the
show make sure to let us know some of
the references you've managed to catch
that's it for our video make sure to hit
that like button and subscribe to our
Channel
see you next time
[Music]